rectangle one is blank meters blank than
rectangle two so let's look at this
rectangle one has a width of 3 meters
rectangle 2 has a width of 9 meters so
rectangle 1 is if you compare 3 to 9
it's going to be 6 meters shorter 6
meters shorter then rectangle 2 when you
see that out of here because 3 meters is
6 less than 9 meters so it's 6 meters
and you know it's not going to be longer
rectangle one is definitely has less
width it's definitely shorter than
rectangle 2 it's 6 meters shorter than
rectangle 2 let's do a few more of these
line 1 is blank centimeters long well we
can measure it we can measure it right
over here line 1 is 9 centimeters long 9
centimeters long line 2 is blank
centimeters long and let me actually
zoom this in a little bit so we can see
a little bit better line 2 is blank
centimeters long so line 2 is 5
centimeters long so let me zoom in a
little bit more even so line 2 is 5
centimeters long line 1 is blank
centimeters blank than line 2
well line 1 is 9 versus 5 so it's 4
centimeters longer than line 2 line 1 is
4 centimeters longer than line 2 and you
can see it right over here to go from
line to line 1 you'd have to add 1 2 3 4
centimeters let's do a few more of this
these triangle one is blank centimeters
long and we can just use the ruler to
measure that it's 3 centimeters long
triangle 2 is blank centimeters long
when we scroll down look at triangle -
triangle 2 is 5 centimeters long so
triangle 2 is 5 centimeters long
triangle 1 is blank centimeters blank
than triangle - well triangle 1 is 2
centimeters shorter than try
two three is two less than five so it's
going to be two centimeters shorter and
remember triangle one we see it's
shorter it's smaller than triangle two
so it makes sense this is shorter how
much shorter two centimeters because
it's three centimeters compared to five
centimeters
let's do one more of these rectangle one
is blank centimeters long well we can
just look right over here it's nine
centimeters long we have one end of the
ruler at one end of the rectangle and
then we just measure off nine
centimeters rectangle two is well looks
like it's six centimeters long six
centimeters long so rectangle one is
longer and it's three centimeters longer
than rectangle two nine centimeters is
three centimeters more than six
centimeters so it's three centimeters
longer rectangle one is the longer
rectangle and we're done